you could only eat one food for the rest
of the life what would it be well for me
it is pizza which is why it's all the
more reason to celebrate this national
pizza day and joining us in the
celebration is our good friend vincent
rotolo owner of good pie how you doing
vincent so good thank you so much for
having me happy national pizza day happy
national pizza day to you too and you
were telling me this is this is cool he
wasn't even planning on talk uh talking
about this but you guys give back on
national pizza day you did this morning
we're part of uh pizza across america
with a charity a national charity called
slice out hunger and dozens and dozens
of pizzerias locally thousands across
america donate pizzas to local food
banks to help feed the hungry people of
las vegas so good you delivered a whole
bunch of pizzas we brought 30 pies over
this morning and uh not only that but
other members of the las vegas pizza
alliance they all joined forces and even
though we're in our own restaurants sure
working hard we're banded together
through this one cause with many many
many pizzaiolos across america i love it
man and vincent i always love your
energy and i love your pizza you have
some really unique offerings uh tell us
what we got today this one in particular
is amazing well we wanted to highlight
all the square pizzas square is one of
the biggest trends in pizza for the last
couple years and moving forward this is
a detroit style pizza our signature
triple pep it's got a pound of pepperoni
a pound of cheese it's one of the best
sellers in the restaurant if you're a
pepperoni lover if you're that guy who
has a pepperoni onesie a pepperoni
sleeping bag you got the pepperoni
pajamas on this is the pizza for you
this here is a sicilian style supreme
and now
we're going to make a grandma the
grandma pizza and this is like your
signature pizza signature style yeah so
here's what happens these proof for at
least 12 hours this proofs for at least
12 minutes it's a thinner and crispier
version of a thicker i like this yeah
yeah so here's what we do let's get some
cheese come on you got to get in there
absolutely we're going to spread the
cheese over here
that's the shredded mozzarella yeah and
you're going to use that entire portion
over the pizza all right you got it and
try to get it in
try to get it off the edge
okay and i'll put the fresh mozzarella
on too all right so it's a blend of
cheeses
now right on the base of this pizza
is garlic oil
and pecorino romano cheese imported
so this grandma is going to actually
have four different cheeses perfect
great job
i used to i used to deliver pizzas back
in the day well if you're looking for
extra work okay i got something you'd be
good all right i got today we're busy
show up at your door
start it right here so here's what we're
going to do with the sauce look we're
going to go from the corner and we're
just going to kind of line it across
really lightly and that's one of the
differences of grandma versus
traditional
the sauce goes on top
okay hashtag sauce on top is a big
movement on social media in the pizza
world so yeah otherwise normally the the
sauce would go first then the cheese and
the toppings but this but this crust is
so thin if you put the sauce on bottom
it would break okay so you're putting
the sauce on top and you're allowing the
cheese to develop the strength and the
structure of the crust right so now look
at that sauce so here's what we're doing
grab meatballs and we're just going to
spread meatballs all over this you got
it now tell us where your location is
it's doing great well we're so blessed
we got so many loyal regulars and we're
in an amazing community the heart of the
arts district at 1212 south main street
it's between california and colorado
just look for that big good pie arrow
sign pointing right to our slice window
we have a slice window for pizza you can
come in and dine we have a full bar an
amazing beverage program and we have
negroni's on draft you know what i love
so much about your story is that uh you
start it up and then boom the pandemic
right you you have worked through it and
everybody you said everybody in that
area is really banding together and
doing everything they can four breweries
three restaurants bakeries all have
opened up since the pandemic hit in a
four block radius within the arch
district it's a bustling community we've
defied all the odds and through local
support of each other we've been able to
be very successful yeah all right how'd
it do you did great so now this would go
into the oven right if you're at home
you're gonna bake this at 500 degrees
for like 10 to 12 minutes so check it
out we'll pop this in oh vincent we
didn't do the magic of tv thing yeah we
got it but we should have had we should
have had it in there oh you pull it down
okay yeah let's put it in come on let's
do it we'll put it in here
okay we'll put this in yeah all right so
now we got the pizza hey is the pizza
ready yeah here we go all right hey it
just baked that that's that's something
and it's cut and garnished already so
check it out you would finish this pizza
with
this grape parsley this is fresh parsley
that we dry ourselves we we actually dry
the parsley to maintain the freshness
right so we don't like the dried herbs
we want everything taste delicious i
love your passion for your craft because
it you pay such attention to where you
get the flour where the pepperoni comes
from all of that is so important to you
and that's why the result is incredible
everything matters so grab a slice check
it out look
we finished this with ricotta meatball
ricotta classic combo and check it out
the hot honey oh
so you got fat salt acid heat sweet
every flavor oh
yeah i have uh
natalia our producers in my ear going oh
yeah please please yeah we got we got
more we got some for everybody guys
mercedes we got some for you too i'm
gonna toss it over to you once again
vincent from
good pie happy national pizza day
everybody happy national pizza day all
right now i'm gonna eat this oh